and I won't forget the men who died some
call them a political liability a leader
with a fragile ego but Donald Trump
again proved he remains the dominant
figure in the U.S Republican movement at
the conservative political action
conference just outside Washington he
drew the biggest loudest most
enthusiastic crowd
[Applause]
back at CPAC with thousands of great and
true American Patriots and that's what
you are
running again for the White House in
2024 he is the man to beat for the
Republican Presidential nomination and
in the halls of the conference many
delegates admitted they won't be swayed
by other interesting options I think
there's one guy that
you need him back in office and I think
the people you know see that if this is
any representation of what people are
thinking he's going to have a very nice
time in 2024. you think you'll quite
easily win the nomination definitely win
the nomination as long as the field
stays big the smaller the field goes I
think it'll be harder for him to win but
if he's one of ten he'll win with 35
percent of the vote from the from the
primaries then go into the general
election
from the former president it was a
familiar message America is failing he
alone can fix it there's only one
president in history who has ever taken
on the entire corrupt establishment in
Washington
and when we win in 2024 we will do it
again even stronger faster and better
he's promised to build 10 new frontier
cities offer a bonus to Americans to
have children but a lot of what he says
on trade and immigration is recycled
from his last presidential run
[Music]
the former president spoke on the day he
released video with January 6 prisoners
singing the U.S national anthem
supporters awaiting trial or convicted
of offenses after the U.S capital was
stormed two years ago I pledge
allegiance to the flag of the United
States of America
Donald Trump is
favorite here among the Grassroots and
in many of the polls to be the
Republican Presidential nominee the
question is is that enough to stop
others who think they can be president
jumping into the race
Alan Fisher Al Jazeera at the CPI
conference in Maryland